that's what I'm I'm in the SEC I'm in
the last D I'm in the last chapter right
now dude think about it dnasty or
whatever yeah it is it's the end do you
start to think I mean is there any do
you feel honestly dude like really do
you feel like it's time for you to have
a family like it's time for you to I
think it is I'm ready I'm I'm not only
am I ready for it but it's like um I
want it I want it and also because I'm
good with kids dude I mean this girl
that I'm seeing now has a kid really
yeah and um How tall is the kid pretty
tall wow you know and um I'm really good
with him I you know uh we got arcades
and um we talk about Pokemon and then we
also do the stuffed we play with the
stuffed animals in his room before he
goes to bed man and I like all that
stuff and I think that I could be a good
dad dude um I'm not good at the
disciplinary stuff I'm not good at like
I probably wouldn't get up in the
morning and make lunch but I'll pick him
up from school and I think that I could
have to say some white [__] you know
what I mean but um yeah but I had but
you know what the love would be there I
think it feels the same with you I think
it would change our lives dude do you
think it would change your life yeah I
think it would man I think it I think it
would what do you think's been the scary
thing for you and I mean I'm happy to
talk about it for me too but like what's
the scary thing you think about going
there about good like doing it you know
it's stuff I have to give up right I got
to give up
Starfield and and stardew Valley and
video
games I can't play it as much yeah um I
think that I would have to change my
sleeping
schedule like today I woke up at 1:30 I
texted you oh dude you have this
sleeping schedule of a wombat I feel
like yeah yeah yeah I do so I'd have to
change that and I think I would change
my language really L I'm filthy yeah
yeah you know what I mean um like
yesterday I I also Behavior So Yesterday
me and uh Jesse were you know how
sometimes you have to take a um from the
rental center for the car to the airport
you have to take a tram you know what I
mean so we were one of those shuttles it
was packed completely quiet and
literally I'm stand me and her are the
only standing and I go watch this and I
bent over and I ripped a fart that was
so loud and it made it so uncomfortable
and me and Jesse were laughing but
everyone was pissed they were pissed
yeah yeah I mean there was one dad that
was like dying laughing cuz it was so
loud but it's like I do that all the
time and I have to change probably that
I dude I'd always you always I feel like
the thing that that's like the uh you
want to always everybody wants to really
rip one in like a public setting yeah
you know let the gods speak you know
yeah why not yeah yeah so it's like um
but do you think you could really do
that and could you live in a house where
when you wake up and your wife is right
there with you in bed and then like then
if you go in the kitchen she's also in
the
kitchen yeah and
also that sounds disturbing to me she's
everywhere right that's the part to me
for some reason that feels overwhelming
and also number
two I notice because you know the girl
that I'm seeing now she's showing her
best
side you know what that's what they do
yeah and I'm showing my best side like I
don't do [__] go rippers yeah you
know what I mean in front of her what is
that blowing it out your nose or
something no just fart oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't do like you know some of my
nashy [__] yeah I I say you know I um I
I I show her the best sides of me yeah
right and um and then you know what
happens is you you commit to the person
and you guys live together and that's
when oh she's in every room oh now it's
a problem that I'm playing video games
too much yeah yeah all those things that
come up so I'm not really interested in
that I'm not doing that but are you
going to let them know first this is
kind of how I live my life like that's
the scarier thing as we get older is I
hear from my friends who haven't gotten
married till other older is that it gets
harder to get like like the it gets
harder to match with somebody cuz you
have too many you know uh but I but when
you I've thrown my boundaries out there
already I've never done this before so
I've set that like you know if I ever
get married we're sleeping on two
separate beds yeah in two separate rooms
yeah and they're like well that's weird
I go I just think that it's better if I
have to go on the road or you know I
mean or I'm playing video games all
night I don't want to keep you up right
and you do your own thing so it's like
that's that and if they don't like that
well then it's not going to work out
yeah I mean there's just certain things
that like also but another thing that I
do is you know I'm like but you know
what dude every meal I pay for whatever
you need you'll have oh wow huh whatever
you need you'll have unlimited dim some
dim some and you can do whatever you
want I will support you yeah if you're
like you know me and my son we want to
go to Canada for like and he's never
seen Vancouver i' fun day go go go go I
don't give a [__] right but it's like
don't get into my [__] and tell me when
to sleep when to wake up do any of that
[__] dude what do you think I think yeah
I think the scary part is just
like I don't know I never wanted to
anybody to be at like I
never I don't know I always like kind of
being by myself I always like being able
to do whatever I want to
do yeah what about this then but that a
certain point it's pretty lonely yeah
let me ask you this could you do this
could you do
this is your part of the house and this
is my part of the house and then you you
design your part the way you want to
design it and every once in a while
several times in a week we'll meet in
the middle of the house have meals smash
do whatever hold hand or whatever but
for the most part I going to stay on
your side you stay on your side would
that be good for you like a Red Rover
Red Rover kind of yeah like a Red Rover
Red Rover yeah yeah yeah yeah like Red
Rover Red Rover I'll see you at dinner
yeah yeah yeah I think I could maybe do
something like that yeah but they would
never go for it you'd have to meet a
girl that would want to do that but I
also I have a problem sometimes of being
up like saying what I need in the
beginning so it's like then things get
going and it's like I don't say what I
need you know and it's like that's
that's why I'm telling you to do it now
I've been trying to do it now like this
is my thing also here's another thing I
say a
front you can never say hey can Sunday
nights be about us and not do standup no
standup will and my business and my
career will always be first be first
really like if it's your birthday yeah
or anniversary yeah yeah if someone dies
and we your Uncle Jimmy dies and we have
to go to his funeral I'll go yeah if we
can smoke there I'll go right yeah yeah
yeah and I also want to dress the way I
want to dress you know what mean I'm
going to wear my pwn show my [__]
cowboy hat bro but my point is is that
so there's certain things like that but
it's like no I'm it's
literally what I do and it's who I am
yeah podcasting and standup and acting
like imagine a girl going yeah you can't
do that movie because it's our
anniversary and you told me you we're
going to go to Paris I no no I'm doing
the movie you know me so you got to say
that up front do you think you'd be
willing to spawn your own child to hatch
your own prawn as they
say I have proof but I'm not going to
tell you what it is my C is strong my
friend really so you can do it s strong
as [__] dude wow boy
boy it's good you got that dim yum on
you yeah I got dim yums dude oh how
about your come I don't know it's it
looks a little risky sometimes but I
haven't really like gotten in there and
you know I haven't gotten in there with
like
a uh like a in U magnifying glass or
anything yeah you don't do that you can
go to the [__] doctor and do it I
think you to do your own home kit I
think you can just put it under like a
um like a microscope yeah can you see if
your semen works well just at
home you don't think you can I'm sure
you can but I just I just never heard
like a home kit but why drive over to
somebody's place you don't really know
waste the doctor waste a load at his
house here we go there you go and what's
the rating like how much what's the max
you can
get
but that's not a chart though is it oh
normal range
yeah um it's that's something I think
about dude but you got to still have
that I have it still you got to have
some beef in the batter homie I still
got some beef in there dude yeah how to
test sperm count oh you can do with
water
even oh you come in water it show yeah
oh they're like sea monies H
yeah welcome to the zoo yeah yeah may I
take your
a that's what I feel like the zoo would
be like in uh in in on a different
planet um and Well a different country I
feel like an Asian Zoo be like welcome
to the zoo can I take your
water and they'd have great food they'd
have the best food um that with the
photo down there is that what sperm
looks like yeah let's get that sperm
let's see a real closeup look of real
sperm can you Google that highres
sperm dude that's high resz right there
look at that yeah whoa
dude whoa dude Papa Got a Brand New Bag
huh whoa dude that's crazy
oh they look great huh I they look
pretty good yeah yeah wow it's very um
and and the ovary looks like the sun it
looks like one of those bosses on uh
breath of the
wild yeah maybe yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah or when that moon comes up you know
what I'm talking about yeah looks like
those those yellow Asian Sprouts that
you at Korean Korean restaurants oh
yeah